alright guys I'm super excited to have
Mike here thank you so much for coming
no problem thanks for having me all
right we've got a we got a lot to cover
so I think a lot of people know you as
the former CEO of MySpace and now
obviously with all of your guys success
at science but you did things before
that I did so let's let's maybe cover
that first sure so I had a you know I'd
started my first company when I was a
when I was a sophomore in college and
that company eventually grew opened an
office right here in New York as well as
the office in Los Angeles I mentally
sold that business I started my second
company right right thereafter and that
ended up becoming a company called user
plain that a wall acquired about five
years after we started within a while I
was a senior vice president and ran some
of their product divisions and and some
of their M&A you know strategy then I
jumped into private equity bought and
sold companies for a large private rocky
firm then ran one of those businesses
that we selves when we sold and I was
recruited out of that into my space when
News Corp had acquired my space and my
space was having challenges and Facebook
was obviously a coming up strong so at
that point you know I was an active
angel investor in Los Angeles
I had advised and mentored and invested
in quite a few different very
early-stage startups was running MySpace
and at the conclusion of that then I
then I started science with a handful
partners got it so let's go back to AOL
real quickly this is during kind of the
early days of the internet he was on an
absolute tear yeah what was that culture
like you know what was kind of people's
thoughts in terms of the potential of
the Internet of the company etc sure so
it was after Abel had been acquired or
kind of merged with Time Warner so he
had this massive media behemoth AOL was
coming off the back of there
huge you know revenue you know revenue
growth from there dial-up business they
still had a substantial dial-up revenue
even when I joined and they began
acquiring their way into the kind of web
to don't and we had built a distributed
communication platform that reached you
know hundreds of millions of users and
they liked this obvious kind of
object-oriented web development where we
had little components of our technology
on lots of different websites touching
millions of users and a wall started
seeing that they really want to be big
and web and versus just relying
completely on their dial-up and their
client traffic so they bought my company
they bought a company called web logs
then they began an acquisition spree
really driven by their CEO at the time
named John Miller to kind of expand into
the web business and frankly the core of
that strategy is what
way-hey well is today so they you know
they actually navigated a very difficult
transition if you can imagine coming off
the back of billions of dollars of
subscription dial-up revenue in the
midst of this you know ever-changing
connectivity environment and then built
themselves into a big media company
absolutely that's super interesting and
has obviously a lot of parallels to to
today alright and so when you get to
MySpace I think a lot of people don't
know kind of the myspace story other
than kind of the jokes of oh don't be
the myspace sure right but but I think
that there's a lot of important lessons
in there right because myspace
ultimately was a successful business for
a period of time right what was kind of
the the things that drove the the
positive side or the growth of that
company so if you think about the time
when myspace launched it was right on
the back of Friendster and Friendster
was one of the first social networks and
one way I think about it is that
everything was kind of a magnet
magnitude of 10 and social network stuff
you assume that six degrees which is one
of the first social networks maybe
reached a million users friends sir meat
reached you know 10 million users
myspace reached 100 million users and
then of course Facebook succeeded in
reaching beyond a billion users so at
the point in myspace coming forth I
think you know we were at a time where
people were still really nervous around
putting their real name into a website
like that was a controversial concept
you still weren't in an Amazon infested
world you weren't putting your credit
card in to buy things online there were
still general fear around identity in
the internet which meant that at the
beginning of myspace they couldn't build
a real social graph right they had to
build your internet identity so people
would say I used myspace to connect with
my internet friends like it was never my
true friends it was always this parallel
shadow of yourself that was
representative through MySpace you know
there was this early stage mistake that
was written into the code by a guy named
Gabe Herman where you could manipulate
the HTML and suddenly people started
personalizing their pages and
customizing all their identity through
MySpace so once again it became kind of
your
you're aspirational self it wasn't
really your true self and that Network
grew but at some point when Facebook
came out I think everyone realized my
gosh you know if you actually connected
to your real friends this product gets
even better
right so if social is good it's
obviously way better when it's left in
real people and my belief is that at the
point of MySpace growing up you know
hitting a hundred million users you know
really reaching for big ad revenue
obviously being acquired by News Corp it
was too late for them to do a
fundamental change into like your real
identity like the DNA had been set and
planted you know what the company had
grown was it was a big company but it
was never quite in the position to do a
full restart saying well we're not about
your internet friends we're not about
your fun customized profiles we're
actually about your real identity and
your real people that really just wasn't
gonna happen absolutely and do you think
that part of this was myspace was
successful in capturing the market that
was available for what the product was
built to do yeah and then Facebook
figured out hey there's just a bigger
market for a different different type of
product yeah I definitely agree and I
think that you know it's like they say
that you know the first person to crash
did well ends up bloody but the second
person has a clear path so I think like
mice you know you know six degrees
started the wall started crashing
through all Friendster crash through
MySpace really opened it up and then
suddenly Facebook just collided right
through there and built like obviously
the behemoth that is today so I don't
think Facebook exists if MySpace hadn't
done what it did but I don't think
myspace at the time could have done what
Facebook did so it's an interesting path
absolutely and then you know while
you're there
obviously there's you know press
pressure and like I stuff like is there
like it's Facebook a rating the myspace
talent and trying to say hey you guys
know stuff about social networks or did
you guys feel like you know it was
fairly separate in terms of the the
types of people or just talk about the
talent we didn't have a lot of talent
crossover I mean myspace was
headquartered in Los Angeles but we did
have global operations they might have
picked up some of our global people the
core LA team was not descended upon by
Facebook recruiters and Facebook played
its own playbook I mean extremely
effectively obviously right and so yeah
we we watched Facebook closely mainly
because I'm beyond them
strategizing us and putting product out
there way faster than myspace did did
the other big concern for us as we were
driving a lot of revenue and that brand
revenue was recognized off of comScore
ratings and so you know the the month I
joined was the month that Facebook's
comScore became bigger than my spaces
and that was a big problem right because
we're out there floating you know
hundreds of millions of dollars of
Revenue and insertion orders with big
major brands and suddenly they're like
whoa how the how that happens so fast
and then suddenly we're on our heels and
so you know I I it wasn't it wasn't you
know if you ever get things if you if
you're a student of business like I am
and curious about so many different
things in technology there's there's no
better experience than walking into a
massively distressed company because it
really challenges you as an athlete on
how you can really navigate your way
through this so the people that were in
that journey with me over you know
whatever that was like a four year
period until we eventually sold off the
assets of MySpace to three or four
different buyers you know we're kind of
some of the best people I've ever worked
with because in the face of massive
distress and huge market question
ability for myspace we built and ran
still a substantial size business we
able to maintain team we're able to
build you know break it off into pieces
and sell it subsequently so you know an
incredible experience not to miss
absolutely no and so you know obviously
that experience kind of pushes you
forward into what is today science yeah
and you guys have built a couple of you
know pretty notable companies there yeah
what was the original thought process
behind science was it just hey let's go
investing companies was it full-on
incubation kind of how were you guys
thinking about it you know as you
started it so we had you know at this
point in my career I had done a lot of
angel investing and I had some big wins
I was at I was an angel and docstoc and
Goodreads and maker studios and seen
like a lot of the kind of top companies
in LA come through my portfolio which
made me happy but I also saw that you
know startups struggle right there's a
massive information asymmetry between
investors corporate partners and startup
founders because you're taking you know
typically very young founders and you're
throwing them the myths of big business
and they're often unprepared for the
skills that they need to go off and
become successful and my belief is look
as an asset
although some venture funds outperformed
standard market you know from a
portfolio view perspective we sit on a
lot of failure I mean you know when
you're when you're talking about inter
capital I'm like well they're great
returns for certain funds but 8 out of
10 startups fail that's a really bad
statistic and my belief was that that if
we had a group of operators you know
that sat in commingled with the startups
that we could reduce that failure rate
maybe we could get in front of that
problem get in front of those problems
and really you know handhold or help
train or help accessorize the talented
these startups to become more successful
and so that was the principle behind
science so you know luckily I found you
know three other like-minded individuals
we all four kind of covered all the core
critical skill sets that a startup we
thought would need and then we you know
hung a shingle raised capital and then
incubated you know at this point you
know hundreds of companies absolutely
and so was there a specific focus on
consumer at the time was there just hey
we think we can help all companies kind
of how did you guys pick what you want
to focus so similar to you know any
startup founder we did what we were
passionate about typically I lead the
general strategic direction of the firm
and at that point I was very passionate
about not being in the ad based business
and if you'd imagine coming off the back
of MySpace and worrying about daily
banner ad served and see PM's and big
insertion orders I just didn't want to
do that it was just it was just mind
numbing for me at that point and so I
said look look I I want to sell stuff
with a credit card I don't want to worry
about retention
I just want to worry about happy
customers and so when we originally
opened our doors we focused really on
two sectors direct to consumer Commerce
and the marketplaces the belief was that
a direct to consumer commerce we thought
the legacy CPG brands were unprepared to
compete in a DTC world we didn't think
they understood their customers names
they really understood the name of their
Walmart rep or their Sears rep at the
time and we thought that there were big
brands to be built to consumer and then
in marketplaces we just believed in the
the changing nature of employment income
and salary we're areas where people can
come together through technology and
earn money and share goods and services
and so the two big companies that came
out of the strategy were was Dollar
Shave Club and then dog vaycay so let's
talk about those
don't talk about the big wins first
Dollar Shave Club for example your guys
idea somebody else's idea how does that
all come together and then you know once
you guys decide okay that we think that
this can be big kind of what are those
first steps so yeah it was it was
definitely not our idea we we were
looking at different CPG startups from
founders obviously evaluating both the
concept and the founder it happened to
be that a friend had referred me to this
fellow named Mike Dubin who came in and
told us his vision around Dollar Shave
Club and he had done some light weight
testing on Groupon he had access to some
product and he felt that there were too
many choices for men to make in the
bathroom compartment they thought that
there was too many brands he needed a
strong brand that connect with men and
make that choice really simple and he
wanted to start with razors and he
happened to have cut this really
fantastic video oh he had the video cut
it already cut the video and legendary
video legendary video and it hit upon
two themes that that I really was
hunting for one was I believed that at
that point YouTube would break a company
like that YouTube is a platform there
would be this merger between content and
commerce and I you know and when he
first pitched me the idea I think the
team and I were like oh my gosh you know
$1 a month this is gonna be so hard to
get to scale like this just sounds so
hard you know but then when he showed me
the video at the very end of the meeting
which I I believe he was reluctant to do
because it wasn't final cut and he had
you know he had honestly talked to a lot
of venture guys and they weren't really
supportive of this concept you know he
you know I saw this I was like look you
know I think that could I think that
could really open up YouTube
like you really understand your brand
and suddenly he really shown you know
shined through to us on on his vision
and so you know we you know we invited
him to become part of science you know
he came in we made an investment we
joined the board we became both his
incubation partner and his investment
partner and he you know moved into our
offices along with a handful of other
you know direct consumer startups at the
time including like me on DS which
became another big brand for us
and so at what point do you say you know
along that journey man we hit that this
is gonna be a you know billion plus
company is it you're looking at the data
every day and you kind of just no look
at it's trending well or is there like a
big inflection point where you you know
it might have been is just when he
release the video right and then at some
point you just know that this is a hit
yeah so we we do what one thing that's
unique about science is that in its and
we can even talk about it relative to
crypto is that we are we are intimate to
daily data so we want to have access at
founder level data within our businesses
as long as they'll permit us because we
are looking for the insights either this
is working this isn't working maybe we
see something that we think works but
the founders aren't quite seeing it with
Dollar Shave Club certainly you saw that
the audience broke out with that video
certainly we saw that that the
conversion retention data was kind of
industry you know industry-leading but
also what we saw was you know an
incredible CEO that really rose up to
that challenge
you know attracted incredible talent
around him built an early stage team
that was just like one of the best early
stage teams and and you know and all
those things came together and you know
we obviously ended up with a lot of
conviction on that business because we
were so close to it absolutely and so
talking about one that didn't go well
right like you bring somebody in they've
got a great idea you you think again hey
great founder sure idea all this stuff
you bring me to the incubation model
we're like what are the common fail
points is it just bad idea that doesn't
work is it the founder doesn't listen
you know kind of where do you see there
so we had yeah we had two fairly
phenomenal misses so one was this fellow
walked into her office one day and he
showed us this this dating app that that
had swiping not to tinder meanwhile
literally within that same week this old
friend of mine named Sean rad showed me
this dating app that was tinder and with
the phone I first saw the non-tender
dating app and because I had in my
private equity days you know I had
worked with a firm and acquired a big
dating network and then we
subsequently sold it to match so I
understood the industry and the moment I
saw this app I was like oh my gosh like
this this methodology is gonna crush I
still have no idea how in the same week
I saw the same app with two different
brands you're like I meant and I've
never asked Sean and I've never asked
the other founder unlike did you see
something from each other how did this
come about it just and sometimes it just
happens that way in startups where
literally it feels like two people have
the same concept the same time and I'm
not under I cannot explain why they're
pranking you maybe maybe they were
pranking me I mean it just felt like a
weird cosmic command since we don't know
so we back so without understanding the
gravity of either these two companies we
back non-tender because obviously tinder
was already backed by I see within a
week of us backing it the developer
takes the app off the App Store and
initiates a lawsuit against the founder
who we had backed turns out the founder
without us really fully knowing was in
this like payment dispute with the
developer and the developer was the one
that had control over the Apple iTunes
account and if you ever go into a
dispute with Apple at the end of the day
they default with whomever owns the
iTunes account so at this point as far
as Apple's concerned the developer owned
the code the developer owned the app we
had no access to the binary we couldn't
manipulate it and we couldn't take it
down and change it so the founder then
spins up another team to basically clone
the app that just got taken down even
though it had users in traction and by
the time the clone was done the complete
battle was over yeah right
tinder was so fast and so on fire that
even the three months it might have
taken us to prop up a new app like the
battle was already already completed and
so it's something we talk a lot about is
just like speed kills yeah right and you
know once you get momentum going and
literally taking an app off the App
Store removing a feature anything you do
that kind of kills that momentum can be
fatal
they don't but but at the same time if
you have two companies same ideas
similar talent the one that could just
iterate faster is likely that's exactly
right yeah I'll tell you I can tell you
a second one
okay I'm second one was we had been
witnessing this change in consumer
behavior
food out of Sweden which was that people
were buying basically ready to cook
meals out of supermarkets pre-chopped
pre ready so we took the concept we
immediately raised a million dollars and
and fluent just gonna be called fresh
dish that was like a pre prepped meal
kit service it was before blue apron had
launched we had on subscription it
quickly jumped to like a quarter million
a month and sales like kind of the
fastest we had seen we hated dealing
with cold chain our team just hated
dealing with you know dicing raw chicken
and figuring out how to basically put
into a box we brought in a very senior
founder who was an older executive that
came out of a very successful e-commerce
company and the first thing he did was
remove the subscription concept he was
like no I just I don't believe this
concept is right for subscription you
know consumers want one-off we were we
were like six months into Dollar Shave
Club so we didn't understand exactly how
powerful subscription was at that point
how critical the moment he removes off
subscription is the same time when
plated in blue apron and these
contenders come up obviously they they
dominate right so in that case you know
the the whether the founder was right or
wrong if that decision was wrong we as
on the board should not have allowed
that decision to be made missed out on a
major opportunity right like so again it
was another weird moment in time that us
along with you know multiple their
startups could have launched the same
thing at the same time one
maneuver in our business model
essentially killed the kill the concept
yeah well so let's move to crypto now
right you guys have science blockchain
yeah similar team similar structure as
the non blockchain side the business
yeah some what we have we have we did a
you know we did a security token I CEO
in 2017 we took that pool of capital the
same way that we have incubation pools
Bulls of capital and we have a dedicated
team that works with startups they pitch
us every day
sometimes we co found the startups with
them sometimes we invest in the startups
in all cases we want some level of
operational involvement to kind of help
them on strategy yeah so very similar
got it and what are the types of
things that pushed you into the
blockchain space was it the developers
you saw we're going into it was it just
hey this piece of technology what kind
of initially got you guys interested
well so we we originally got very
interested in two thousand thirteen and
fourteen and so we had set up a
lightweight mining operation we were
actually about to launch our own
exchange but you know similar to a lot
of people at that time because we're
funded by institutional investors I got
very nervous over the legality of what
we were dealing with and so we kind of
put everything on pause in late 2016 you
know there's a network of crypto
enthusiasts out of LA and we're very
tied in to these these these people and
in late 2016 you know you could feel it
was happening like it was all coming
back a theory em was just starting to
really move and people understood there
was something special happening there so
you go into 2017 and we said look look
we have to build here so so at that
point we dove into the yeah we did we do
oven if accrediting our own bespoke
vehicle to see what we would to see what
we could do got it and what are the
areas you guys are interested in right
now so you know when we looked at
blockchain broadly I felt that although
you know everybody in you know everybody
and their mother has a concept of some
token ICO 95 percent of it is like
incenting incentivizing users to do
stuff which is almost like the most
boring and obvious concept around
blockchain and we looked at things that
we thought were you know I have an
original strategy map that we built
early 2017 that still just holds true
we certainly FinTech fine like let's
just assume obviously that's logical
second was Security's fine like creating
liquid tradable objects around you know
around securities I love that right but
then we thought about technology we
looked at things like ticketing you know
ticketing is a highly logical use of
blockchain we looked at encrypted
messaging we loved that we looked at
areas where it was logical for users to
have a non centralised and non corporate
control controlled data store medical
records I still love credit scores I
still love areas where there's a piece
of me that needs to exist in this
digital manifestation I don't want
Experian owning that piece of me but I
do want that piece of me to exist
someplace where it has some level of
control and encryption and permission
basis
and so we we found these areas where we
thought it was logical to build and then
we found founders and startups that
we're building in those areas got it and
when you look out across the landscape
right now where do you think we are in
terms of I don't want to say cycles but
just you know it feels like there's a
lot of talent rushing in it feels like
there's a lot of experimentation going
on I think I'm the infrastructure side
so you've got companies like coinbase
gemini circle you know even Robin Hood
etc that are kind of what I would
consider more crypto incumbents right so
these are people who have figured out
business models with revenue yeah are
either at profitability or headed that
way
and they seem like like true technology
companies in a centralized fashion for
the most part yeah on the other side is
where all the experimentation the decent
reliable decentralized world is
happening
it doesn't physically attracted there
yet right it feels like there's a lot of
ideas there's a lot of you know people
trying but we haven't really seen a a
breakout company application etc is that
what you guys are seeing or do you guys
look at it differently than just kind of
centralized decentralized so yeah I
think your assessments correct and and
the way I kind of framed it up is
imagine if we imagine if you know Ivan
mean they spend a lot of time to look at
the early days of the stock exchange but
it's almost like the stock exchange and
all the supporting financial
infrastructure around the stock exchange
was suddenly built but there's no really
good companies to put on the exchange
right that's kind of it feels kind of
like where we're at right which is even
the companies you're mentioning coinbase
and robin hood and gemini and these
different custodian platforms and
trading platforms as change platforms
it's all predicated on something of
actual high value and desirability to be
floated on these things yeah but to your
point outside of a magical store of
value that is or is not Bitcoin or eath
or whatever you want to call it there's
not that many products that we all would
want to trade on an actual stock
exchange if we looked at that way so we
do look for companies like actually
building and using whatever chain
they're going to be on one of the
reasons why I think we're this pickle
we're in right now which is basically
that finances so finance and finance
infrastructure and capital is so far
ahead of development is a direct result
of 2017 in the ICS which is that
people with bad concepts and people with
great concepts all were essentially
overfunded and they were over funded
also without any governance which means
that they ended up with pools of capital
with essentially zero accountability and
which means that there's not a lot of
pressure on release dates board reviews
executive comp right there's small
groups typically engineering lead
sitting on a ton of capital with no
urgency which is why we're just not
seeing the right stuff come to market
now you know of course I believe that
our portfolios do have more discipline
because we're working with them
hand-in-hand on getting their products
to market on whatever chain they're
supporting but for the most part I think
a lot of these projects are very
stagnant yeah and you know I come out of
the kind of growth the metrics etc world
you know I was having worked at Facebook
so we can know what we'll talk about the
myspace Facebook stuff later but but I
think that you know the people who
figured out how to be data-driven mm-hmm
high levels of iteration or frequent
levels of iteration in a centralized
world one big right if you look at the
Facebook's of the world his Twitter's
the Google's etc they figured out how to
do that yeah something I I've been
thinking more and more about is is it
actually going to be true the people who
figure out how to do that stuff in the
decentralized world on a global scale
will actually win you know magnitudes
bigger right is is then the opportunity
or are they actually somewhat parallel
right Facebook's a global company and so
whether it's sexualize decentralized
it's not really gonna matter well I
think that the I think that focusing on
and very similar to the philosophy that
you experienced inside Facebook
obviously with our you know art equity
driven startups everything is everything
looks like a live hedge fund right like
they're trading in their marketing and
their performance and all their apps are
monitoring a live basis they have the
religion of data beautiful on the crypto
side I wish we were at that point but I
don't think we are because that's also
predicated on general adoption of this
tech yep right and so you know the the
challenge that we're dealing with and I
think we're about to break through with
some major
deels is getting large massive
corporations to pick up and adopt these
protocols of these in essence kind of
b2b software platforms because for the
most part most of these technologies are
b2b software platforms and for the most
part they're going to need mass level
you know partnership and adoption after
they get that I would love to focus on
the optimization and the daily data
right now I just want big breakthrough
deals just to start getting volume on
these networks which is what people
really need absolutely yeah and in part
of this is you need some technology
doesn't have to be the best technology
but it made me some technology they need
the validation and Trust whether that
comes through corporations that comes
through time right there's a whole much
ways you can get that yeah and then you
get the usage and can kind of get into
the data because part of this is you
can't really do a lot of the you know
powerful data-driven decision making
iteration yeah unless you have data
that's right that's exactly right yeah
you need volume have and right now most
of the volume that we all talk about and
even looking to our earlier conversation
before this podcast around active DAPs a
lot of it is self supporting within the
industry so the data people are just
like even you think about somebody
releasing their next chain that's x
times faster than one of the current
chains but the only use case right now
is really the current chains trading
among each other or these DAPs trading
tokens within their current chains it's
not like something is like oh my gosh
only if i had a stronger chain i had
this massive corporate client that wants
to onboard I don't even think we're at
that point yep yeah I think that's
completely fair what do you think about
Bitcoin itself right so obviously
there's a bunch of company building
that's going on yeah
Bitcoin may be the most obvious most
simple yeah you know cortical company
being built right in front of our eyes
and yeah it's almost too easy
right it feels sure people kind of
overlook it and they're like oh what
about all the other shiny stuff yeah how
do you guys look at it so there's a I
had a really great conversation Saturday
night with some Bitcoin enthusiasts and
then some I guess counter Bitcoin
enthusiasts and the conclusion I pulled
back from was this is that in the
broad-based global consumer world the
breast product does not always win
right and right now like aside from
people that might listen to your podcast
or people that I know within the crypto
industry most people know only one thing
which is Bitcoin so if you think that
bitcoin is a brand from a crypto
perspective it is probably the only mass
recognized brand that exists today in
crypto it may not be the best someone
may have a faster transit mechanism to
have a better chain with additional
features but for the general person if
they're gonna enter into crypto I still
think they're probably gonna enter into
Bitcoin and if a normal place is going
to god forbid actually accept a payment
system in crypto they're probably gonna
start with Bitcoin it doesn't mean that
bitcoins best I just think that that
brand may prove to actually hold more
weight than we're all giving it credit
for which means that it might you know
it might have a lot of long lasting
power yeah it is um the it's funny
because as like with all rules in life
there's always exceptions and so there's
this book I think I might be called
think bigger and it talks about this
idea of you know in many categories the
first mover one so coke right perhaps
you can try as hard as they want sheriff
but cokes out in front yeah right and so
you kind of go through a bunch of these
now flip sides go social network search
engines etc yeah technology world
actually the first one hasn't won true
right and so I don't want to say that
it's binary in terms of oh tech industry
operates one way another intercept
operate the other way yeah but with
Bitcoin around this like human
psychology this brand awareness is one
component and then to is also by being
first it was able to get a grab a lion's
share of the computing power true right
and so and that's like the network lock
in yeah that's right and it becomes
pretty hard I think that like to me
that's the part that you have to not
only convince somebody to donate their
computing power or rent their computing
power which is to get them to leave what
they're doing yeah that's right right
and I think that's gonna be the big
challenge for anyone who wants to unseat
Bitcoin is how do you convince a minor
to do that okay yeah it might be really
hard and if you think historically like
why was why did gold become gold right
it's not gold isn't the certainly
titanium is more value
gold or platinum or you know other other
raw minerals could have been a
competitor to gold but at some point
when gold was recognized as the default
currency or the default standard of
trade suddenly that lasted what hundreds
I mean I don't know it's down 5,000
years right and so it's not that it's
the best right and so I definitely agree
Bitcoin has a substantial advantage
because of the miners and because of the
amount of network locking the tap and
the amount of capital that's poured into
it but I think from a consumer
perspective it would take something very
major right so a major global platform a
major product coming out with the
ability to access billions of people to
truly unseat it and you know unlike the
Facebook MySpace wars I mean at the end
of the day if MySpace and Facebook at
their heart they at their heart they're
more entertainment than they are utility
you know um you know correct crypto at
this point is more of a utility so it's
not like I can like or not like Bitcoin
like I might have an opinion on whether
I do or don't like my experience at
Facebook if you look at Bitcoin is
purely a payment mechanism or a store
value like I shouldn't have a feeling
about it it's a utility right now with
that stated Google certainly is a
utility and certainly broke apart from
Yahoo and the other search engines at
the time that almost felt a little bit
more like entertainment so a Bitcoin
stays in utility bucket they probably
have a lot longer lasting power than we
expect yeah look I I I'm fascinated by
the narrative that Bitcoin could become
money store value global reserve
currency low stuff and the part that to
me feels like there is accelerating
momentum is when you look at places like
Venezuela right where you know Bitcoin
is not the best store value truck right
if every Venezuelan could they would buy
US dollars right right because that is a
more stable store value than the blue VR
or Bitcoin right but when you start
talking to some of the people who either
are there or a family there what they
say is you know look the Bolivia are
absolutely not gonna be sustainable yep
and so I could try to get the US dollars
it's dangerous right so actual the the
ability to get there they've gotta do
some pretty crazy stuff to be able get
the US dollar and then to is the
government come take it from them right
right if it's under their match
if it's in their bank account and all
these different things and so you not
only get the currency issues but you get
the government issues it's great and
with Bitcoin obviously you start
resolving some of that stuff and so it's
almost like this trade-off between the
store value is good enough mm-hm right
and I also want the other advantages
that come along with this digital asset
that's true and so the part that feels
much more like a tech company that is
valuable right take a Dollar Shave Club
some people want Dollar Shave Club
because they don't wanna pick a brand
yeah right some people want it because I
just forget to buy razors yeah right and
it shows up idea one because it's cheap
but it brings different utility or value
prop to different people okay the same
offering that's right
with Bitcoin it feels very similar to
that like that there's different values
that people can get out of the same
asset that's right
well and I mean that you know I like the
Venezuela example I think that you could
use you could swap all those terms for
China too so oh interesting you know
there's a lot of their substantial
restrictions on Chinese people moving
their money into other currencies and I
have a feeling that I let's just say
like I've talked enough people to
believe that that if you're in China
you're feeling very happy about being
able to move your money into crypto more
so than keeping it within your local
currency and it's almost easier than
going into other international
currencies and I don't know we don't
talk about it a lot and people don't
really want to recognize it that's a big
factor in this but I think it's actually
a really huge factor so I definitely
agree with that
I also think that one of the beauty you
know I've had to counter arguments on
the Bitcoin side of the world one is
with enthusiasts that are really upset
because they believe because Bitcoin
doesn't have a CEO and a management team
that it's somewhat directionless and
they're frustrated by that and they
think it should be much more powerful
and much more valuable than it is
because because it frankly it's been
depressed because it doesn't have kind
of consolidated push on the flip side
the companies right now that do have you
know clear management teams on top of
their their token or their platform I'm
not sure they're clearly telling the
audience what it's for you know and I
spend a lot of time with these CEOs of
all the major tokens and I often leave
the conversation feeling like I'm really
unclear what they want this thing to be
so I want to have
kind of happy that no one's telling me
what bitcoin wants it to be in the
public's like look you know yeah I'm in
Venezuela and I want my capital in
Bitcoin because that's just a safer
place for me or you know or I just
believe it's a long-term store value
because I believe in the brand and a
certain sense that's almost better
because Bitcoin is out there saying
we're creating a venture fund to fund
you know millions of little tiny
startups that are all gonna be built on
top of Bitcoin and some of them are
gonna be doing all sorts of different
things I'm just not sure it would be as
clean as it is now absolutely yeah and
part of this too is so there's the
technology argument around the utility
in different use cases and one thing
that we've you know really tried to
unpack and I don't even know if we
actually have answers to this but today
your interaction with the financial
system is you who probably account sure
to separate things used for two separate
things but in all that's where you store
and buy and sell yeah value yeah right
in the digital world what we're seeing
is we've got tokenize or digitized
currency right in a Bitcoin or others
now we're starting to see these tokenize
securities right so I've see you guys
tokenized some equity type stuff that's
right and I think that you're gonna end
up seeing the commodities bonds and all
this stuff will get tokenizer
digitigrade well like a coin base a
circle a Gemini they actually are gonna
create a world where you could hold all
of those different assets in one single
location that's right and it changes the
user experience not of a single asset it
actually changes the user experience
that individuals have with the financial
system that's right right and you start
thinking through the repercussions not
just in the Western world yeah right and
you look you guys have built big global
companies and brands right and and the
one trend that I think goes untalked
about in crypto is the African countries
who were almost completely unbanked a
decade ago that's right actually have
better mobile banking than here in the
US that's right or you know we may see
this with the rest of the financial
system in other parts of the world where
they just leapfrog yeah the Western
world stays behind that's right I
totally agree and there's a few themes
you hit upon there that I that I think
are really fascinating and one is them
we were looking at a bunch of startups
that are approaching the merger of your
of your brokerage account and your
checking account where their statement
is like look what we're going to do is
you're gonna deposit money with us we're
gonna give you a standard ATM card when
you're money sitting with us we will be
investing it into bonds and we'll be
investing into things that are low yield
a low risk but actually get you X
percent return on this trajectory and
then every time you swipe your ATM card
we're gonna dynamically be selling your
position in those products to basically
get your capital available to pay for
your you know your restaurant bill that
night and so I like this this bleeding
where you're combining the the
performance-oriented brokerage with your
kind of cash account and I think that
you know banks have a lot of financial
incentive right now to keep those two
things separate because you can then
charge a lot of fees on both and then
base can arbitrage your checking account
balance or your savings account balance
into their own debt products and then
you know brokers can lock up your cap
with all this stuff so it so I think
there is a change the financial system
where you have startups thinking about
bringing these two things together so I
love that the second theme you hit upon
which somebody also was talking me a lot
about is this concept where like could
you be in a world where your bank
account was all obviously in the digital
assets and you could be holding
commodities and then every time you you
know swiped your card you would be
dynamically selling the right commodity
at that time based on price and
arbitrage right so again like having
your money work for you in a different
way and do it through tokenized
securities I love that view as well I
worry that the the US financial system
is highly motivated not to allow that
view to happen and I don't really want
to it's hard to bet against that US
financial system and the third piece of
your argument which I definitely agree
is that where you have countries where
for instance they didn't have land lines
they jump right to cell phones that was
a incredible leapfrog moment on
infrastructure for those countries when
you have countries like Kenya where they
typically didn't have typical banking
and credit card infrastructure and they
immediately went right on to m-pesa
their digital payment platform within
their telephone providers that was a
huge change for them right and they're
arguably you know one of the core
countries in Africa that are already
existing on a digital currency that no
one seems to want to really talk about
that has nothing to do with Bitcoin
there's probably not even truly
decentralized but highly effective yeah
look look we we like to say the US
first digital currency most people
interact with right 92% of the money
supplies digital and so you know it if
you look in New York City for example
people who carry around cash right
versus credit yeah it has been a
dwindling number yeah and then if you
look at the subway system so subway card
is like a real-world utility token yeah
that's right a lot of the projects are
trying to do this is I have to take my
US dollars I have to exchange it for my
subway card then I go and I can swipe to
use something that's right right how
many of those do we need in Arlen high
great that there's some for sure that it
makes sense in in a system so sub is a
great example in the real world yeah I
may be some gift cards that like a
certain company whatever but but when
you really think about your everyday
life there's just not that many
opportunities for that and so I think
we're gonna get big compression on the
utility token sigh great and on the
financial side though there's a lot of
opportunity yeah so you definitely just
feels like there's gonna be a migration
there over time to like more quality
type problems assault I totally agree
yeah you have to ask yourself like how
often have you been like I really want
transferability of my airline miles like
I really need to do that every day I
wish this was a transferable token
without a centralized system right the
reality is like we all have we all have
lots of point systems you know we have
credits on our on our on our gift cards
we have you know whatever you know it's
subway rides and our Metro cards we have
miles with our airline accounts but it's
not that frequently I want to move them
all around right which in theory would
be the benefit of a decentralized system
so we're already doing all this it works
pretty pretty well right everyone
interactions these things all day but on
the flip side you know in the security
system our security tokens you have a
lot of products that are liquid which
become really insane for me so we
focused really heavily on REITs and a
company New York called real blocks that
will eventually be announcing a big
partnership with and what we what we
love about them is they are figuring out
ways to onboard REIT products into a
tokenized security system because REITs
are fairly vanilla like we can take
portions of reach and put into a
tradable object they're not really
traded now there's a lot of REIT
inventory like like you know an
unbelievable amount of capital locked up
and reads um they're small players that
want to buy into REITs but they can't
afford the minimum size blocks when the
big players do their offerings and so I
think that if
we see an asset class like reeds start
putting out hopefully billions of
dollars of product in you know in
security security tokens that allow the
trade ability of such I think you could
see a lot of volume on that and that
could be one of the first products that
really opens up that security token
exchange it solves a real problem yeah
right that makes make sense all right so
let's do some rapid fire questions sure
afore we wrap up what's the one thing
that you think in crypto that a high
majority of other people would disagree
hmm well I think you know you obviously
have a lot of people really believing
almost every pitch as I mentioned
earlier talks about you can incentivize
people's use is the main use of crypto
and coming out of my space right and and
building a lot of consumer products I
think everyone here would be surprised
at how hard it is to get people to
change their behaviors even if you do
incentivize them so the number of times
I've been pitched the like we're Spotify
on crypto where you get paid for every
song you listen to I'm just telling you
it's not going to work out for you you
know and by the way every I've gotten so
many pitches that were the Facebook for
crypto right where you earn money back
off of your add views there have been
incentivize aren't there though I can't
who I don't care that's what I'm good is
like there's no network effect on this
stuff and there have been so there's so
many ways right now by the way like in
the internet world where you can get
paid to click on ads trust me it's out
there but no one you'd system right or
if they use them it's small at small
buckets
so I'm coupons we're one of the first
like incentivize use products out there
right and if you think about the
population actually Clips coupons it's
not actually that large so I don't
believe that tokens as incentivized
system to compete against major fortune
100 consumer product companies is a
realistic use case absolutely no I tend
to agree with that all right so if you
could wave a magic wand and change one
regulation what would it be change or
improve you don't really change it but
you can improve it well I mean right now
you know there's I feel like there's so
many regulations I would love to change
or improve you know I really don't like
the 99 you know investor limit that we
have off of what reg D Holdings it
causes a really big problem
which basically means that even if I go
through the process of only working with
accredited investors which is what we do
I still have this 99 investor limit the
purpose not a purpose of one of the
upsides of a crypto security token
offering is that I could be much more
broadly available to a lot of people the
moment you restricted $2.99 you
essentially are just basically limiting
it back to high net worth and so the
concept of you getting lots of people
involved in your offering and you doing
it the right way through a security
token offering and then you're also
adhering to the no investor rule I don't
know it just kind of flies in the face
of innovation and a little bit so I
think that would be a nice regulation to
change absolutely other than a company
that you guys are building or have
funded what do you think the most
important company in crypto is I mean
let's see I mean there there's obviously
there's obvious companies in crypto with
coinbase and etc I'd like to give you a
non-obvious answer oh gosh I have to
really think about this listen I think
the miners are substantially overlooked
you know I mean when I spend time with
miners I'm spending time with these like
hardware nerds that are operating the
core of our infrastructure at a very
quiet level yep I think that they move
price more than anyone wants to actually
recognize I think there are a massive
underlying force of this industry that
people don't talk about so I said why
don't we give some attention the miners
and say that the miners are somewhat
unrecognized as like a massive component
to the story I think that's fair yeah
all right so let's forget about crypto
for a second okay this is my one non
crypto concern and then I end every
podcast with letting you ask me a
question okay so think about that for a
second we have to admit that aliens are
real okay all right we always think of
aliens as human-like right whenever you
seem depicted in sci-fi in movies etc
okay nobody ever really talks about
alien animals okay so do we think
there's alien animals and do we think
aliens have pets
that's a good question I'm gonna assume
yes to both of those answers well I mean
well I I I'm assuming that whatever form
and aliens gonna take shape will be
really based on like the
biology in the the physics of whatever
planet they they're on so if you assume
that aliens might look different than us
in any form then you have to assume that
their animals are gonna look different
than us if you believe in evolution then
you have to believe in evolution from
interplanetary scale so like you have to
assume that they had subspecies before
they were highly intelligent creatures
and they if there is different physics
on that planet it has to be different
than what it is here it's a hundred
percent that's a pretty reasonable
argument I wish I could you say more
unreasoning everyone thinks about space
no one thinks about the animals no I
great and I'm sure they have pets
actually that's a cursive or Astarte a
space PETA protect the rights of alien
species I like that all right so what
one question do you have for me hmm so
what are the like you see a bunch of
projects um if you were to you know if
you had 50 million dollars to invest
into one company and you had an epic
team that was going to run that company
and it was going to support the overall
growth within the crypto industry what
would you want that company to do so
their answers in two ways there's if I
was gonna invest the capital and just
push the industry forward in general
yeah right and not worry about financial
returns sure and there's if there was
financial return okay on the financial
return side I think that whatever
company wins building the global
securities exchange so doesn't any
betoken just digital securities on a
global scale so not jurisdiction by
jurisdiction but anyone anywhere can buy
any asset anywhere in a regulatory
compliant way yeah that will be a you
know multi-billion hundreds of billions
of dollar worth company all right so
whoever figures that one now it's gonna
be a huge huge winner okay if you know
who that is let me know why man okay
the if I was not worried about the
financial return I would actually put it
behind an effort to go and drive
adoption of Bitcoin yeah in developing
worlds no not specifically around
governments and central banks yeah in
the thought process there being
we're already seeing kind of the Fiat
experiment fail a couple of countries
yeah and so if if we could go in however
do technology through literally just
conversation whatever it is and
convinced these countries that you
should switch over to this decentralized
you know technology yeah now they're
gonna lose some power right and so
there's got to be I can't just go in and
say you have to do this yeah I'm not
gonna work but but I do think that once
you get kind of this slippery slope
going of some of the smaller less
developed countries
switching over yep there will be an
acceleration of adoption yeah and it
won't be just a buying it like the like
the EU is not just like we're gonna get
rid of the euro we're gonna go you know
bitcoin yeah you get more coexistence at
first right and then what I believe will
happen at some point in future could be
a hundred years out people will be able
to vote with their dollars right or
their euros or whatever and they'll say
look I'm gonna put my value in one of
these two sorts of value means that
exchange yeah and you'll just see the
flows of that value will tell you what
is better or what's more desired right
and so I think that like right now we're
not even at a point where people have
like they believe they have the option
right so it's more of just like I have
the US dollar oh I took ten basis points
you know and I bought some Bitcoin yep
when it actually becomes more kind of
like a decision and and I can choose
between the two and they're somewhat
equally weighted yep I think that's
gonna be pretty powerful and so there's
probably some like I don't know it's not
a technology piece really that drives
that adoption I really do think it's
education and and it's the you know kind
of just going banging on doors so great
right so I don't know that's what I
would do I like that 50 million bucks
would would get us like three days in
crypto world though depending on how the
volatility absolutely no man look this
is awesome I really appreciate you you
coming on and we'll have do it again
sounds great thanks for having me